hey everybody and welcome to a
confrontational wild ride with Stevo we
go ahead and come straight at adam22
about the gang stuff the you know what
stuff and all of his people leaving no
jumper I mean man a lot of people jump
ship and we didn't even bat an eyelash
we just went straight at him about it
and I'll tell you what he is a solid
podcast every time I happen to really
like the guy he just told us how it is
and let me tell you how it is I'm on my
tour bus I'm finishing up the bucket
list tour the final Show's ever and it's
gonna end in Gainesville so if you're in
Ohio Pennsylvania
North Carolina Florida I mean dude get
on it at stevo.com for tickets and if
you're ready to see some juicy
confrontational action then let's get
into it
with the orange for a basketball
oh sweet oh my God you changed the color
yeah sick
orange for a threesome
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen Adam 22. we back in
here in the flesh for the second time
I'm hype to be here first time was in
the flesh right in the bus yeah In the
Flesh for the second time which is uh
rarefied air man really oh I didn't even
think about that yeah because someone
has to perform pretty well on our
podcast for them to be invited back hell
yeah and so many people were on Zoom oh
yeah that of the people who are invited
back not many uh come back a second time
and
to put in the flesh well I'm Overjoyed
to be here so yeah I mean and your
podcasts have been performing well
recently yeah yeah we did some good ones
recently yeah the ones that you've been
on people want to hear what you have to
say yeah a lot of people asking for
interviews you're right yeah check this
out
um on the no jumper podcast which I
believe we're simultaneously uploading
yes I told you that I've been building
out my media department and
um I've got a guy who's hired strictly
just to do podcast shorts right just
little podcast shorts so one of the
first short clips that this guy makes
and puts out is he he calls it the truth
all caps truth truth and all kinds the
truth about Adam 22 and why he something
or other you know like I didn't I
remember like I I saw it just kind of
come through my feed and I was like I
remember thinking well that seems kind
of odd like how do we know what the
truth is like who are we to say what the
truth is yeah but from a clickbait
perspective you definitely want to
always be like filling the audience in
on some truth that they are not
currently aware of right and and uh I
mean the guy is definitely a
sophisticated dude knows what he's doing
but it was just Eerie how just about as
soon as I saw that clip
thought oh that's kind of weird then I
get a text from adam22 like hey I just
saw that clip you're done to do the
podcast and I'm thinking like oh no
adam22 wants me back on no jumper so he
can like call you out call me out maybe
kick my ass I don't know and uh and I
was like yeah absolutely I'd love to
come back on no jumper and I hope that
uh there was nothing disrespectful no no
no I watched it I I don't mind I kind of
gave the whole world a free pass on
whatever they wanted to have as their
opinions in terms of this situation so I
didn't even watch like a ton of it I'm
pretty sure I watched you guys clip but
it's not like it's not something where I
was like stressing people freaking out
over it or whatever I understand it's
kind of a shocking idea you know I mean
I I uh don't think that we had anything
controversial to say about it I think
that my opinion was that whether you
consider the whole you know Lena with
the other guy situation to be an L or a
w doesn't even matter in your world
because it just like made you go crazy
and get tons of attention yeah I mean
that is kind of a weird thing you uh a
reality that you get to once you're like
deriving a large percentage of your
income from only fans is like
the only way that you're going to be
able to get more money every month from
only fans is to get more attention so
sometimes that can be like you just make
really good content you know you do
podcasts or whatever but like for a lot
of these girls it's just short form
content nothing moves faster than tick
tocks and YouTube shorts and Instagram
reels and whatnot don't they have to be
careful to not mention that site
otherwise they get their stuff taken
down on Tick Tock a lot of times in
particular like reels I think you'd be
all right YouTube shorts they tend to be
pretty open-minded but in terms of tick
tock definitely you have to be really
careful but like you know for us it's
like we when me and her kind of started
discussing this idea that was a big part
of it it was just like oh people are
gonna freak out about this like this
will just get a ton of attention so then
it was kind of weird for people to be
talking about it as if like oh Adam is
so pissed like he's so mad because
everybody's talking about this and it's
like bro the whole reason why we did it
was because we knew it was something
that people wouldn't be able to resist
talking about you know and dude it's
such a crazy like double standard that
we live in like it just doesn't even
check out that like what you do with the
plug Talk podcast like there's all of
this like other women like all this all
of this crazy stuff going on in your
relationship but heaven forbid like that
your wife should go shoot a scene with
another dude I mean I totally get why
there's a double standard because the
truth is is that I mean people perceive
it completely differently and it just
really is different in a lot of like
significant ways because it's just like
you saw it with the way that this dude
Jason loved who did it like he kind of
like went on a little bit of a media
tour afterwards talking about it and
said some stuff that we kind of
perceived as like disrespectful you know
and that's kind of crazy when you think
about it because it's like we've never
had that problem with girls like you
know never has it been a consideration
that like Lena and I were gonna sleep
with a girl and then that girl was gonna
go and say something crazy about Lena or
some [__] you know it's Linda not Lena
right yeah yeah okay a lot of people get
it wrong can you um give me an example
of something that Jason love said
he just was kind of just talking it's
been a while I haven't really had to
think about it in a minute but he was
just kind of talking in a way that I
took as kind of disrespectful and like
oh like I didn't think about that
beforehand of like oh this dude's gonna
actually do like a whole little mini
media tour where he just talks about
this [__] and kind of the the the
interviewers are gonna try to bait him
into saying [__] about me so I can't
even like really put it all on him when
obviously he's going on platforms and
people are trying super hard to get him
to say some crazy [__] so then mean like
meanwhile me and her when we've talked
about doing more stuff like this in the
future she's like anytime we do it we're
going to do a group chat with the guy
and like fully have a whole conversation
about like we didn't like it when he did
this like just please don't like put it
out like this whatever because like I
don't know I mean probably nobody's
gonna ever care as much as the Jason
loved one you know where if we could do
that 10 more times it's gonna just keep
getting less interesting to people as we
keep doing it but like for sure like a
partnership agreement of some sort yeah
it just is a little different and in
particular because of the way the the
world perceives it but also just because
well yeah it's all about perception but
it's definitely like you know us not
doing it for seven years in our
relationship and then finally doing it
was just too irresistible for people
right especially right after you got
married yeah right like that's the crazy
part but how how about this everybody uh
finds it so controversial and and so uh
like
whatever like scandalous that your wife
shot a scene with a another man who's a
professional star in this industry but
nobody even like thinks twice about like
you're giving a guy a high five Eiffel
Tower like in the same like well my wife
is watching yeah yeah definitely me and
some French dude uh did an Eiffel Tower
while we're banging a girl together the
other day that was pretty epic shout out
to Alex uh I believe it was his name but
uh yeah I don't know I mean me and her
have like a very
non-traditional relationship I guess
just in the sense that like but I mean
the we are it's weird because there's so
many different types of
polyamorous relationships and stuff you
know you have ones where the guy can
cheat and the girl can and you have ones
where they're both open and you have
ones where like I know some people who
they'll they'll be able to go sleep with
a girl their wife can go sleep with a
guy but they'll never see it and they'll
never talk about it you know like
there'll never be a video that they get
to watch whereas I know some guys like I
know one guy who's a real like by
definition cuck in the sense that he
his fetish his girlfriend at one point
he was telling her I want you to go to
the club I want you to find a black guy
with a big ass dick I want you to suck
it film it on your phone or have him
film it and then you're gonna come home
and we're gonna watch it together and
we're gonna [__] while we watch it like
that was his thing he wanted to see all
that [__] for me and her it really is
just like an on-camera thing because we
don't really hook up with other girls
off camera like we could it's a
possibility it just doesn't really
happen we're just kind of busy and stuff
so it's like we don't and we don't party
we don't go out we're not at the club
but like all the situations that I could
imagine it just kind of happening like
we don't really exist in those
situations you know so like uh yeah for
me and her it's basically basically just
like an on-camera thing that you know we
we realized that we could kind of make
more money and make people more excited
about our relationship and more
interested in our business by just kind
of opening it up so so are you are you
do you consider yourself an entrepreneur
YouTuber porn star are all of the above
all these should you go to like AVN
shows and stuff yeah we won a porn
podcast of the Year this year at ABN so
that was pretty cool yeah I
Hawk and I follow you on Instagram and I
said something that uh I think might be
controversial I certainly don't mean it
at all disrespectfully but whenever I've
seen plug talk Instagram posts and and
they're always like it's you and Lena
and then you know the the third party
woman right I don't think that ever has
the third party woman been as attractive
as Lena wow that's a hell of a
compliment thank you Stevo appreciate
that do you agree with him oh he's
kidding you understand that I mean to be
honest we've had some like unbelievably
hot girls on over the years definitely
gave her a run for her money but for
sure I don't know there's something
about my girl that like whenever we're
hooking up with another Shake no matter
how good she looks like I'm always kind
of like really like more excited to [__]
my wife in the threesome like I don't
know it's just something about her like
just I've always found I'm very
irresistible in a way that I can't even
really put into words when you guys
agree to the Jason love thing was there
ever a moment in time where you might
have thought oh [__] this might have
been a bad idea yeah after she did it
for sure
once like the the sort of like just a
weird like feeling in the stomach of
just like oh dude like was this a good
idea like I don't know like like I kind
of started to second-guess myself and
then I talked about it on the podcast
and she put up this like Instagram reel
where she basically like you know was
kind of laughing into the camera while
he's walking up and back and uh that was
when I really started to get the
response from people of like basically
like I guess I just didn't realize how
many people were going to be infuriated
over this but you knew that was gonna
happen though but not not I didn't know
it was going to be as crazy as it was or
I didn't know like the whole world was
gonna stop and just be like all right
you know what [__] this dude let's get
him you know like that that was kind of
a surprise but what did you do when she
was like when she's like okay I'm gonna
go did you go to Baskin Robbins and have
an ice cream by yourself or like what
would you do there
this is a perfect example of a time when
you find yourself in a pressure cooker
and you don't know how to handle the
situation which makes me very happy that
this episode is brought to you by better
help it is an online service which
matches people up with professional
licensed therapists and let me tell you
it is very important even if you're not
in a pressure cooker moment like for me
it's all about my relationship I want to
make sure that my relationship stays
healthy so I work on my relationship in
therapy to keep it healthy that's why
therapy is so important to me and I
believe it can really help you I mean
better help has matched over 3 million
people with therapists and you don't
have to go to the like physical location
you can do it online very easy and if
you go to betterhelp.com
that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Stevo you can get 10
off your first month again it's a big
deal therapy helps me I think it can
help you so go to betterhelp.com Stevo
for 10 off your first month and let's
get back to it
one thing about me that a lot of my uh
hip-hop oriented fans don't necessarily
know is that I love playing poker more
than almost anything in the world and I
already was scheduled to play online
that day because like when I want to
play tournaments you kind of have to be
ready to be on the computer on the
computer for like eight to ten hours you
know so it's like I have to like really
schedule it and you basically only want
to play tournaments on Sunday on the
internet because there's just way more
tournaments way more people playing and
they're way bigger buy-ins you know so
like for me on a Sunday when I play
poker I'll I'll play maybe like 10 to 15
000 worth of tournaments like all the
buy-ins are between like you know 50
bucks and like a thousand bucks or two
thousand bucks and so that's what I was
already scheduled to do that day and
there's nothing that like would take my
mind off of
what else is going on in the world like
for instance my wife getting [__] by
this big ass black guy more than like me
playing poker tournaments so that's what
I was doing all day and I think that's
why I I didn't really think about it
much while it was happening because I'm
playing like 10 poker tournaments at the
same time and like you have to be really
really [__] focused to like not time
out on your decisions when you're
playing that many tournaments so that
was probably the best thing I could have
been doing at that time in in terms of
like my mind not wandering or like
thinking about it when she came back
from the scene was there any sort of
like awkwardness no between you and her
she came back and it was all good like
she got Dave's Hot Chicken delivered so
that was pretty dope and then we uh
talked about it and then we ended up
hooking up and then you know it was
pretty I mean I kind of I talked to her
about my feelings throughout it like
when I was feeling a little jealous or a
little bit like weird about the reaction
I was getting I just kind of talked to
her about it you know and then like as
time went by it just felt more and more
like not a big deal and that's kind of
the the thing I've heard from a lot of
people who are in more in porn couples
or in like polyamorous relationships
where it's like you know there's always
going to be this strange feeling in the
beginning where you feel kind of like
sick to your stomach or just sort of
like uneasy about it and in particular
you know I had to go through that with
you know many many millions of people
laughing at me but you know I feel like
it uh you know now it doesn't really
feel like as big a deal like me and her
are going to do a bunch of like
Instagram and uh YouTube content where
we're sort of like searching for the
next guy we're kind of like planning all
that out right now and like that now the
idea of like oh like why is this
supposed to be a big deal like it
definitely doesn't feel like a big deal
to me now even though like when it first
happened it kind of felt like a little
bit of a thing do you think it made the
relationship stronger in a sense I think
in a sense yeah just because like you
know she had this like insane windfall
of money and attention and I guess me
too and that sort of like
it just sort of made like it made her
really happy to be able to like you know
really cash out at this point in her
career I guess and like that sort of
like she was just like really really
thankful to me for being open-minded
enough to let it happen you know and I
think that she was just really turned on
by the sense of security of me like
being willing to allow her to do that so
I think it like really kind of upped the
ante in our personal sex lives so in
that way for sure I think it was good
yeah I feel like a lot of people came at
you and you don't ever seem to get riled
up I was watching you on the whatever
podcast and that Christian but the
pastor guy and he was saying some [__]
that they really want him to go on that
podcast so I like those guys if you want
to make your way to Santa Barbara uh he
would be super hyped to have you yeah
wait is it uh like they're religious and
they're no no no no the whatever I don't
know who the main guy is he's always at
the grinder yeah he I like him but he
always has like a myriad of guests on
and different perspectives
eating podcast so he'll have like a
bunch of chicks and a bunch of dudes and
a lot of times they kind of end up
arguing about dating type stuff and
everything sometimes it'll be kind of
like a religious versus
liberal debate type thing yeah he
doesn't have a big audience yeah he had
that Pastor on and he was like it was
almost like he was trying to evangelize
you but like yeah he was saying some
things that maybe kind of pushed your
buttons but like you always seem you
answer the questions well you never
overreacted and if anything like you're
really calm during that and you and Lena
as well yeah I mean my whole thing is
that if people disagree with my life
decisions that doesn't really like
bother me that doesn't make me feel
angry at them it doesn't make me feel
like I I want to like get it like it
doesn't make me angry that they disagree
with my decisions and at the same time
a lot of their concerns are concerns
that I have as well like when they say
inevitably they get to well you have a
child like what about when your kid
finds out about this you know it's like
it's not like I haven't thought about
that like I [__] thought about that
plenty I just then also made the
decision to go through with it and I do
think it's kind of silly that people
think like well you know Mom and Dad
hooking up with like hundreds of girls
online is okay but then as soon as
there's one guy in the picture that that
if anything I think like when I picture
myself explaining this to my like you
know teenage daughter or like at
whatever Point she decides that she
wants me to explain the porn side of my
life I feel like it will probably seem a
bit more fair if it's like yeah Mom and
Dad have both done stuff with other
people as well on camera or whatever but
yeah I don't I don't hold it against
people for taking issue with it I
definitely I know it's not for everybody
and that's one of the weird things about
it is that a lot of people take us doing
us doing this kind of content or her
sleeping with another guy on camera as
me and her wanting this change for the
world that we want everyone to do this
and that like in particular in our case
it's like we did this from a porn
perspective from a money perspective
from a business perspective not like
like if my girl was just dying to [__]
another guy honestly she would have just
told me like hey like we should have a
threesome with another guy that wasn't
what we did we planned it all out and
did it on camera like in terms of just
the sheer enjoyment of having sex
she would have probably had a much
better time doing it off camera you know
it's like we did it on camera because
it's a business thing you know
it turned out that
it wasn't just on TMZ but it was like an
ongoing like you know article after
article on TMZ and
um
a few things in life bring me more joy
than being on TMZ
just because you know like especially
now what if you get on TMZ then next
thing you know everyone else seems to
get their news from from TMZ like yeah
there's something about it right we're
like TMZ will hit me up to do some
content and I just always say yes
whereas like a lot of people I would say
no but for some reason it just being TMZ
you feel like yes like like I was doing
cardio in my neighborhood on that top
left one and they just texted me and
they're like can we ask you this
question and I'm like well I'm going to
be doing cardio for later next I don't
want to see you I'm like yeah I'm like I
just turned my location on and I'm like
yeah I mean like pull up on me if you
want and they come through and they just
feel me talking about something but TMZ
is like that's like real La culture
right there like you gotta respect it
well some of the comments when like
people bring up TMZ they're like oh God
they get their news from TMZ but like
TMZ is really [__] credible right
yeah yeah can you say that for the
record because there's a lot of people
that are like oh God TMZ but like
they're I think TMZ is a legitimate news
source they break all kinds of news they
uh like they hear it first a lot of
times yeah yeah when Kobe died yeah you
know like the like seven minutes after
if anything that's the argument against
him is like you guys are too fast it's
kind of creepy it's kind of weird like
you should let the families uh find out
about this at their own pace or whatever
they found out about Kanye West's
divorce before he found out about it
yeah right
um
the uh yeah dude I found out about the
Ryan Dunn passing from a call from TMZ
asking me for a comment about it
oh that's six o'clock in the morning
um
but uh
it's just crazy the the last time when
um I had a thing and that and it wasn't
even one where I reached out to them
like uh they they hit me up and they're
like did you just get arrested in London
for jumping off the Tower of London
Bridge and I was like oh sort of I've
got a great video for you here you know
like and I was actually gonna call you
yeah I was getting ready to hit you up
uh they uh posted the story and um in
the following like two days
there were so many it was the biggest
like got picked up everywhere like crazy
and and my publicist sent me an email
with uh all of the the stories like
compiled into one email like all the
links and everybody have a joke with
with Knox so Knoxville would never send
anybody his press I sent it to everybody
so I sent synagogue so like yo check out
all my press and his response was so
funny he wrote back
I was Stevo thank you so much for
compiling all 49 of these links he
really saved me a lot of work
so there are 49 different Publications
that picked up that story from TMZ it
used to be the Associated Press AP was
like the Hub where now it's TMZ dude
yeah if you can get them to talk about
you everybody will follow behind right
and so that that I bring this up because
I think that to the extent that this
whole thing with uh with Lena and Jason
love being a windfall of money and
attention I gotta believe TMZ had a lot
to do with that yeah probably I mean it
honestly just like overnight as soon as
we started talking about it it was just
like every podcast just talking about it
and just I had so many people that I
don't even think they knew about me
before or they just never bothered to
talk about me before who were just
weighing in one weird thing is just like
how people will title their video as if
you're the [__] Antichrist and then
when you actually watch it it's kind of
like a more nuanced like
conversation you know but if you've just
read the title you would think like oh
my God they hate me which is that's a
weird part about it but then also just
like I don't know I mean for me it's
like if you're in a gay relationship or
you're in a trans relationship you're in
an open relationship I don't give a [__]
I don't like I just have no dog in that
fight I don't care at all like I might
have some personal opinions about things
but I would never think to like really
care but somehow like the the whole idea
of like letting someone sleep with your
wife is just the most insanely offensive
notion to people and it's just like it
was kind of weird to be on the receiving
end of it of just like oh like people
really are just infuriated by this and
especially as like a porn couple which
to me that was kind of the thing that I
thought would make it seem acceptable to
an extent to people is like well we are
a porn couple so it's like people are
going to be able to kind of understand
that like the way people talked about it
and reported on it you would like almost
have no idea that I do porn too you
would think that like she was just fully
like taking control of the relationship
and being like I'm gonna do whatever the
[__] I want when in reality it was just
like very meticulous planned out thing
by us you know yeah who was who came up
with the idea first
um well it kind of just came to be an
idea because we did this like Tick Tock
with Jason love in uh January in Vegas
where uh I think I said who's the
hottest girl here and he said or he said
he like put his arm around Lena and then
like walked off camera for The Tick Tock
and like I was just like oh like
standing there and it was fake but uh
after that it just kind of became this
like huge swell of people requesting uh
that and so you know she she mentioned
it and like you know I kind of saw the
the value or whatever we hadn't
necessarily had a lot of like PR around
that time and like you know with the
plug talk thing it's like we we work
with a different girl every week
but sometimes it doesn't feel like it's
kind of hard to like make people care
about that like for some reason that
doesn't really like get people like
super excited like when we first started
it it was kind of viral and it's like at
a certain point you just you work with a
different person each week and it just
doesn't really seem like it gets people
going that much so like from our
perspective it was kind of like oh this
is like a way to sort of make [__] more
exciting you know
yeah yeah so
here's one
the last time we linked up for for a
podcast I had a buddy of mine
um reach out and he says hey man I saw
you were over there at the no jumper uh
headquarters he says man be really
careful be really careful or like I'm
I'm worried about you there's like
really like you know Shady bad people
like
and uh I I didn't really feel that way I
remember when I walked in like the like
this heavy marijuana I'm just thinking
oh man I wonder if they could like maybe
air out at the pot that's why we got a
bigger spot now so it'll be a little bit
more easiness wait I had no problem with
that today but but what uh I just was
struck by that because there was genuine
concern coming from this buddy of mine
and uh like that's kind of like your
reactions
interesting fact about my buddy who
expressed this concern is that he might
have been into a little bit of gang
activity himself back in the day plus he
was a big time football player and how
happy are we that football is back baby
and you know who's an official's betting
partner of the NFL it's DraftKings
sports book baby and boy do they have a
deal for you they're ready to hook you
up with 200 in bonus bets if you bet
just five bucks on NFL this week one and
they've got a new deal every week for
the whole month of September that's if
you download the DraftKings sports book
app and use the promo code Stevo yep
that's right they're hooking people up
like it's going out of style so if
you're planning on betting on football
anyway then hallelujah for DraftKings
sports book now
download the app and use the promo code
Stevo and good luck baby gambling
problem call 1-800 Gambler or visit
www.1800.net in New York call
877-h-o-p-e-n-y or text h-o-p-e-n-y
467-369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit ccpg.org please
play responsibly on behalf of boot
Hill's Casino and Resort KS 21 plus age
varies by jurisdiction void in Ontario
cdkng.co football for eligibility terms
and responsible gaming resources bonus
bets expire seven days after issuance
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply jump on this have a blast and
let's get back to it
I mean we've had a lot of shady [__]
over the years especially when we're on
Melrose with a situation where the guy
put the gun in my face and all that kind
of stuff and like uh that reputation has
kind of like followed us to a certain
extent because you know now you know
people just kind of think of stuff like
that it's kind of hard for them to get
that out of their memory but uh yeah and
I mean realistically it's like we
interview a lot of gang members there
have been a few different incidents over
the years not like shootings or anything
like that but you know people just sort
of running into each other that don't
get along and there's a heated argument
behind the scenes or some [__] like that
and the video comes out or whatever but
like even even today like there was like
probably 20 gang members in in there
like doing the interview right before
yours and you know
to me it's nothing because I know that
by virtue of them coming through with
people that have respect for me that
they're not going to do anything shitty
while they're here and that I just kind
of like live with faith in that you know
and like in particular somebody like you
I mean you would have nothing to worry
about because what the [__] do they care
even if they don't know you it's just
like oh some random white guy walked in
here like gives a [__] you know so I
mean to me I think we run a pretty tight
ship now we have security our security
pretty much like whenever we're doing
interviews or whatever they they take
everybody's uh weapons away or whatever
before they're allowed to enter the
premises yeah is there like a metal
detector or anything
um he does run a metal detector over
them yeah and he finds a lot of guns and
knives that he confiscates for the
duration of their interview yeah wow
what's the biggest gun you've taken away
from somebody oh you know I don't really
have like an Uzi or like an AKA I don't
get involved so I don't know if it's
been anything beyond a handgun that
would be pretty [__] crazy if you
found an Uzi stick it out of somebody
yeah or something yeah can you weigh in
for for us on the the ynw Melly case do
you think he's going to get off or do
you think he's gonna stay in for a while
ah well it's like he either gets like
life basically or like subtlety right is
what they're going I think the death
penalty's still on the table Yeah but uh
do I think he's gonna beat it I don't
know I've been kind of amazed by the
extent to which his uh Team his managers
and his family are like super super
confident that he's going to get off
um but then at the same time uh I don't
know there is a lot of evidence that
looks really [__] bad for him I know
that like in Florida they straight up
have a a real
desire to get him that they've had for
making an example all the time yeah
because he he beat like uh some murder
charge or something back in the day
shoot at a cop or something yeah well
that that was actually part of this uh
these charges I think I don't know but
like he there's been other murder
investigations that he got off on in the
past and I remember even when I first
met him he told me like the cops where
I'm from he's like they want me they
want me so bad you know so then when
they got him for all this [__] I guess I
wasn't really that surprised but I don't
know I mean as somebody who was like
actually really close with him he's a
weird one because I have so many friends
who either got killed or overdosed like
in the early stage of my career like
Draco the ruler a little peep or
um juice world or whatever and or x uh
exercise but then somebody like Melly I
haven't seen him in five years it's kind
of like weird to be like oh [__] like he
might actually come back and we might
actually be able to like you know run
around and do stuff together again
hmm man there was a
like
for your whole new media like
conglomerate like you had all these
different podcasts and stuff and I
remember seeing stuff saying that like
you had people who were in your crew and
then they left and started their own
podcast that was like really
controversial yeah like I kind of slowly
built up this uh Team of dudes who are
doing podcasts on the channel and then
within like the same sort of month-long
period like basically like seven or
eight of those guys basically ended up
leaving like in two different groups and
basically started two separate podcasts
you know like where with them basically
doing the exact same thing they were
doing on the jumper but doing it on
their own platform and stuff but I mean
we have so many different hosts on the
channel That like honestly like it
wasn't really that big of a deal for us
to kind of rebuild and start and have
all of our shows kind of come back
together and stuff so honestly like that
was like a very stressful thing to go
through for a little while there but I
think the the thing that was painful
about it was just that they sort of like
painted this weird victim narrative on
the way out to try to like convince the
fans that they had been like treated
pretty badly but then when it came down
to it they were basically unable to like
identify anything that actually happened
that was like shitty or bad for them you
know it was like the truth is is that
they just kind of thought that they had
enough juice to be able to do what they
were doing on the jumper on their own
and that they thought that they were
basically like worth more than they
actually were you know and so Jackie The
Joke Man leaving Howard Stern yeah it
was that kind of thing where like they
just kind of I think they overestimated
how important they were to no Jumper's
success and they thought that if they
left that everything would just fall
apart and then that didn't really happen
and now like a lot of their friends are
on the channel and like kind of have the
jobs that they had before so then
meanwhile like their stuff isn't really
doing that good compared to how it was
doing when it was on the jumper so so I
know that they're kind of feeling like
[__] like why do we why did we do this
but they kind of have to keep the whole
image going that they're like happy and
boastful and like having a good time but
I think like deep down inside they
probably know they [__] up but you
know maybe in the future we'll be able
to reunite once the the once time kind
of humbles them a little bit once they
bend the knee and Kiss the Ring no they
don't even have to kiss the ring I mean
well I guess I have a ring now yeah but
it's hard out there for a Pimp yeah you
know
that'd be kind of gay they don't have to
kiss the ring
so so we have a friend that's on this
podcast that's getting into the porn
industry I'm not gonna say any names but
do you have any advice for somebody
starting out that's like trying to get
their numbers up on in the porn world
well it's kind of weird because like the
girls all get bbls and fake boobs so
like even if they're kind of like a
regular looking girl they can get you
know fake lips installed and they get
you know uh the BBL the FH whatever what
do you say I'm so sorry I just
interrupted I was doing so great up
until then
um on his podcast I gave him a bottle of
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
which is available on Amazon he looked
at the the character the the label on
our Stevo's hot sauce bottle and he says
oh this this looks like you have BBL
yeah and I'm like what the hell yeah
yeah yeah yeah no definitely yeah you
got a little Badonkadonk but yeah
yeah but no like the whole thing was it
wasn't that I uh oh no okay if you want
to be a guy getting into porn it's like
really you just have to have a big dick
that's like the whole thing and so I'm
kind of uh like mine is like I think six
and three quarters or so like I'm still
under seven but reasonably uh girthy and
I'm still like very much at the smaller
end of the spectrum compared to like all
the other dudes in porn because like
this is certainly not my specialty I
wasn't born to do this once you really
get in the game you start to realize
that there's dudes injecting stuff into
their dicks and that there's all kinds
of different Beef It Up or to make it
hard or what you know it's still a
little bit of a mystery to me but I know
that they definitely do stuff like they
just inject like sort of like silicone
into it or something to just like add
girth to it I think but definitely some
of these guys are just like Naturals
just born with huge dicks and stuff so
that's definitely like a lot of guys
seem like they want me to tell them
you could still do it even if you don't
have a big dick and it's like my thing
is like I feel like I have a small dick
so it's like probably I would say mine
is kind of like the smallest but but you
just won an award so that's yeah I think
the idea is kind of more or the award is
more like oh like because the idea for
the podcast and stuff more so than like
my particular like that's my nightmare I
don't want to be compared to the Johnny
Sins and the dreads of the world because
it's just they're in a different
category I got this though dude like
I've always thought and then it's been a
long time since I watched porn like
that's kind of a no-fly zone for me so
like I'm a sexually sober nerd but um
when I was super into watching it
um
it bothered me that uh that everybody
had to have such a big wiener I
don't know and
and qualify that statement because my
buddy my jackass buddy Chris Pony has
said something I really resonated with
me we I agree he said that um
he has no interest in girl on girl
content he says watching lesbian porn is
like watching Escape video with nothing
but ramps and nobody riding them yeah no
I'm totally in agreement with that I
can't watch lesbian porn yeah it's a
snooze Fest right so now now the reason
why I think that's something that
resonates with people is because
like there's nothing to relate to
there's no point of of like uh focused
for for relating like you know that's
why watching uh co-ed porn you know a
guy and a girl like you're kind of
somehow like vicariously you're related
your point of reference you're relating
to the guy and so now like the big huge
wieners kind of ruined that for me
because it makes it unrelatable
I always said that if I could like you
know have my wish there would be a
category of you know on PornHub or
whatever like a category like if not
like small weiner porn reasonable
wieners
yeah
I'm sure there's every category yeah out
there and that's one thing that girls
will tell you about their only fans is
that one of the biggest requests is that
people want dick ratings and a lot of
times it'll be guys with big dicks who
want the girl to tell them that their
dick is small or it'll be guys with
small dicks that want them to tell them
that their dick is big or sometimes
it'll be small dicks where they want the
girl to tell them that their dick is
small you know so it's like there's all
kinds of like different stuff and I I
feel like a lot of people probably get
kind of turned off by the giant dick
thing even for me like my boy dread he's
like he's pretty much got the biggest
dick in the world and I'm subscribed to
his only fans but sometimes like I when
girls are sucking his dick like bro the
thing is as long as this [__]
microphone stand it's like it says
they're giving them head and they're
sucking about this much of it right they
can't really you know whereas like when
I'm getting head when I'm doing a porno
a lot of times the girls got her [__]
lips on my pubic hair like because
they're able to consume the whole thing
whereas they can never do that to this
guy yeah yeah it's crazy Vinnie would
you ever let your girl go on plug talk
and I thought we were confronting Adam
22 on this episode woof Vinnie just got
blasted and same to say most people's
answer to that question is a simple no
and no used to be my answer to accepting
help in the bedroom but I don't know
what I was so afraid of because it turns
out that a little help in the bedroom is
a lot of fun and that's why I love
Bluetooth tablets why because they've
got the same active ingredient as both
Viagra and Cialis except they only cost
a fraction of the price and for the
listeners of the Wild Ride podcast you
can get an entire month supply of
Bluetooth tablets completely for free
all you pay is five bucks for shipping I
mean come on couldn't be easier couldn't
be more fun you go to bluetooth.com use
the promo code Stevo take care of the
prescription right there in record time
with online medical provider and boom an
entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets is on its way to you for free
all you pay is five bucks in shipping
and man I can assure you it's a lot of
fun so go to bluetooth.com and use the
promo code Stevo now let's get back to
it
haha
I don't know we would have to sit down
here she has okay well she does porn
then that's I thought like I'm thinking
she's just a regular girl I'm like damn
you should probably said no I can't
check this out at one point I uh well I
I I like to keep keep my my body hair
shaved you know like uh if you could
like oh you know shave it me too sub I
remember uh shaving one time and and uh
just just for some reason I thought I
gotta put it in a bag you know put it in
a bag and then I did it again did again
next thing you know I I ended up like
saving all of my pubes and body hair all
the shavings I saved in a bag for like
two years
when when I when and it was still wasn't
even that much right and and I had the
the crazy idea I'm gonna make a a
Sasquatch suit out of pubic hair out of
your own hair yeah but but I'm just
getting nowhere near it so I was like
okay you know what sadly for this to
become a reality I need to like you know
have a Pew party so I did like a meet up
I was like I have cake everybody if
you're a guy with like lots of pubic
hair bring me some tubes bring a razor
and like I I had this crazy event where
like literally like a hundred dude shut
up it's at least 100 wait so they were
like 300 it was like somebody just got
covered after that event but they didn't
come with a bag of pubes they came and
shaved it yeah yeah so and and I did the
Shaving right so like and everybody had
to bring their wage because it would
have been weird if one razor is going
from one guy to the next guy so
everybody brought their own razor that
was when I learned that manscaped abs
absolutely makes the best grooming
products for shaving pubes well I can
confirm because that is also what I use
to shave my body yeah hands down so like
I as I'm doing I've filled up like a
grocery bag full of just random dudes
cubes in this session and what was
striking about it and why I bring this
to you is that
my uh opinion of what an average sized
wiener is changed dramatically over the
course of that event because you saw so
many small dicks yeah and I wasn't out
there trying to look at people's wieners
you could easily expose your pubes and
not your wiener but guys were just like
carelessly like carelessly just pull
them down I saw way more wieners that I
didn't sign up to look at people's
wieners I just accidentally
coincidentally did no and the app like
there's a thing called a micropenis yes
I saw dudes I I saw dudes pull their
their waistline down like their belt
lying down and it was like it like
picture like an actual light switch like
once they're at their their life their
belt went down a certain bit like it's
just like the the little micro penis
went up like a like a light switch I was
so shocked at how small a wiener it can
get I had no no idea before then and I
was equally shocked at how far off my
impression of what an average size
wiener is it's wait by the end of that
day I felt like I am huge yeah no
because I used to live in Koreatown and
I would go to the gym you want to see
some small dicks you go to the gym in
Koreatown man I [__] would be walking
through that locker room just like oh my
[__] god that barely exists that's a
caterpillar that's a [__] a shrimp yo
just there's barely a dick like I don't
know it's kind of amazing there's a
couple dicks that popped out when Steve
was shaving and I was like oh [__] like
that guy must be embarrassed because
he's facing the crowd and I was like oh
my God and then and then I looked up at
his face and he's just like yeah like
stoked on life it was probably kind of
freeing for him because he probably
walks around with like a little bit of
Shame for his tiny dick so I don't even
think that the the younger generation
like somebody told me that because the
theory is that the reason why there's
like so like micropenises now there's
more micropenises than ever and people
are becoming like hairless is because of
the like the the heated up Plastics when
you drink water you know how they say
like oh don't drink water when it's like
heat it up because there's like the
plastic chemicals are bad for you that's
why we drink liquid death baby yeah well
they said like the the heat up like one
of the things that it does it's like
it's like a heated up plastic thing
where it's like making like the Next
Generation like there's more micro
penises there's like less hair on
people's body it's like it really have
an effect our boobs getting bigger
that are probably because of the
hormones in the milk I
think well we also have an obesity
epidemic in this country so that
probably adds to it and then also like I
remember I found out like how much
taller dudes are now versus yeah 100 200
300 years ago and I thought it was all
genetics like tall people sleeping with
other tall people and then having tall
children but then it's probably mostly
nutrition you know Isaac can you look up
the average height and weight from
somebody that fought in the Civil War
yeah like five foot tall yeah you know
like five nine one Thirty
just think about how little they were
eating in comparison to US
five eight one forty five a 140 what do
you think the average height of a dude
is these days not bad 5 8 not that short
it's not that different my but 140.
oh
all right I mean it sounds very small
yeah so what's the average person now
it's 197 pounds is average and the
average height is the average height is
five out of nine 197. so that they
didn't get any taller they just got a
lot of water yeah dude think about that
50 pounds but I'm that's unbelievable
what is everybody making fun of Donald
Trump's mug shot because they said he's
six to 215. Yo his his claimed height
and weight is my exact height and weight
so I feel like I'm in a little bit
better shape than Donald Trump like yeah
he's like pretty much but then they also
have but then okay if you were to look
at me with my shirt off and then look at
all I've seen all these tweets with like
you know football players and soccer
players who are 215 6'3 and they look
like [__] superheroes because they're
like all muscle whereas like I'm less
muscle more fat so it's like you can
have like a very wide variety of
different body types I'm six foot to
like 214. oh yeah so like
I mean yeah if we were to stand next to
each other with our shirts off we
probably wouldn't look too different I
think you can kick my ass
wait I'm looking at your fingers they
look kind of like yeah I buy my nails
I'm a nervous now it looks like you had
like parts of them cut off of like the
actual finger no I bite my nails too
it's a bad habit
I don't know do you have any like
martial arts training or anything else
you know about it oh yeah I've taken six
classes of Jiu Jitsu I'm a white belt I
might have taken like 20 classes of
Jiu-Jitsu so that's my guess I did it
for like maybe six months or something
nah but I I don't think I can fight
that's why I like because I'm pretty
sure I could get a good Bag doing the
celebrity boxing thing but about it like
fighter like you kind of like pretty
mellow I don't yeah I don't think I have
like really great hand-eye coordination
I don't really think that like fighting
is probably what I should be putting my
attention into but it's like but it's
like almost everybody who's in my
position seems to be doing boxing
matches you know like if you're like a
mid-level influencer you got something
going on it's like oh you do this you
get to make tons of content about it you
get to actually get paid to fight you
you've thought about it I'm too old for
that so I thought I don't know if
anyone's too old
I mean when uh when Justin Bieber came
out with a 2 tweet saying I want to
fight Tom Cruise in the Octagon I went
racing to Vegas to go uh record with
Dana White and so on I said to Dana
White I think Tom Cruise is afraid of
Jeb student Bieber but I'm not and I
want to fight Justin Bieber but I knew
that it would never happen right it's
like Bradley Martin yeah you think you
could take me yeah oh my God I meant to
ask you everybody I meant to ask you
about this Fouseytube Drama Oh Yeah
Millions
well dude I feel is that the guy that
would dress up at like a Mortal Kombat
in elevators and like yes he also
claimed that I made millions of dollars
off the shirt when I was for the record
we might have made like thirty thousand
dollars which is still a lot but like
that's not a million right never mind
multiple Millions right is he out of his
mind and look at how there's you just
have some random oh I guess this might
actually be the real shirt but like as
soon as you make a shirt these days you
just have so many people bootlegging a
shirt that's why you got a silk screen
it yeah that's why you gotta like dude
sold by big [__]
you got to do the the full deal silk
screen that got Brian from whatever he
has a charity that he started called BLM
but it stands for big labias matter
which I think is actually kind of
honorable that he's trying to raise
awareness about labias of all sizes you
know what's your whole take on this
foosie thing do you think it's like
strategic in a way where like him going
crazy I don't think it's strategic at
all I think he's actually losing it but
I mean this is just something that
happens to him every couple years it
seems is that he just you know because
he's he's been doing content since 2018.
for like the past five years he's been
streaming longer than that
in 2018 is when he lost his [__] mind
and had this whole thing at fusi Khan in
2018 and like we all sort of documented
it and stuff and in retrospect it's like
damn we were really kind of cloud
chasing off of a dude who was having a
manic episode and then he just literally
like has continued to stream and stuff
but now he's having another manic
episode and so everybody is tuned in and
watching and you know one thing that I
thought was super interesting that I
found out and all this is like
when I used to watch his Vlogs back in
the day in like 2015 2016. he would
always talk about his addiction but he
would never be specified yeah he would
never say what it was and I'd always be
like trying to figure it out in my head
and I'm like you know you're not doing
hard drugs because I can just tell by
like your skin and like your your body
and stuff it just doesn't look like
you're [__] up like if you were an
alcoholic or something you would seem
drunk so I was just always trying to
figure it out and like through this he
he actually ended up coming clean and
admitting that he was addicted to
prostitutes so that kind of like totally
adds up because that's something that
you can go do and then you like return
to your normal life and it seems like
nothing is wrong right right but yeah I
mean I I feel
I guess I just feel bad for him but I
mean he is such a [__] that it's
almost kind of hard to be about foreign
like 51.50 even though in Florida that's
called a baker but I'm I don't think
he's been on live again and I think the
whole problem is is that he's just like
he he removes everybody from his life
that wants to try to help him or like
you know guide him in the right
direction because it's so obvious to
everybody that he's just losing his
[__] mind and that things are going
very badly but anybody who wants to take
issue with that like you know you have a
support system around you where I'm sure
if you started [__] up that he's
gonna call you out and you have like a
bunch of people around you that are
going to be able to make it clear to you
that this isn't cool he just like
removes everybody from his life as soon
as they try to help him out you know I
think he came in Vitality should get
into the ring I think they were best
friends at a certain point right yeah
um the uh thing was we were on your
podcast again we would double upload so
simultaneous uploads yeah we talked
about totally different stuff on each
podcast so absolutely consume both of
them and on your podcast you're you're
saying how uh when people become
successful it's kind of human nature
that they start treating other people
badly they think they're better than
other people and and I said well you
know there's Growing Pains to becoming
like a famous person and
um it just seems that that with fousey
like
he's not through the growing pains it
seems like for the last five years or so
though that he's been pretty humble and
pretty low-key because he's sort of like
you know lost everything in terms of his
riches and his YouTube Fame and
everything and you know he's streaming
and he had like a smaller audience and
stuff but now as soon as he started to
like do really good again it just like
completely [__] him up where he just
started to just behave like a total
imbecile and yeah and I think what's
trying to stream 24 7 for a whole year
is just I'm pretty sure he doesn't have
a lot of money he did at a certain point
because of YouTube and everything but
I'm pretty sure he squandered most of it
I want to root for him I want to be like
you know down for him six million
that shit's never yeah would you have
him on the Pod I would I I I I think I
would have him on the Pod and that's
just shamelessly
like I'm just doing it for views but uh
but I'll say this I was driving around
with Isaac the other day and we were
talking about the um the latest fousey
episode I think it was with Isaac and um
he says uh you know well he's just
having this manic episode is not really
him and I said well
consider it like this somebody's an
alcoholic they're super drunk they they
say something like sure yeah they were
drunk but what they said was the troops
sometimes right I've had alcoholics in
my life who would say things that
clearly were not true you know right I
understand sometimes following demonic
episodes last normally but let me finish
my thought here is that with what I see
with Fuji tube yes he's having a manic
episode but
what he's saying is douchey you know
like like the the manic episode might be
like you know clouding his judgment to
let the the douchey things be said but
you're either a douchey or not like you
know like you got to be a douche to say
I'm so viral like yeah you don't know
who I am like all that kind of stuff no
yeah I mean it's both where it's like
you know he's kind of an [__] even
when he's not having the manic episode
but like this IRL streaming thing of
just like walking around all [__] day
with a camera filming yourself going to
clubs and bars and restaurants and just
making like a a constant 24-hour live
stream out of your life every person
that I've ever known who did this for
any period of time it pretty much always
like had a very catastrophically
negative impact on their life like ice
Poseidon I mean I won't even begin to
get into it but go look it up it
completely ruined his entire life
basically like you know I have I I know
a bunch of people who've had like real
problems and it's people will tune in
and watch you on a consistent basis if
they feel like you might crash out and
ruin your entire life that's just super
interesting to them you know like
whereas if you have it all together a
lot of times like people kind of stop
tuning in because they just realize like
like I guarantee you if I started
smoking crack that like my podcast views
will go through the roof because you
would be watching a train wreck in slow
motion you know I mean dude that's so
funny I got I got clean and sober in
2008 yeah
and in 2011 Charlie Sheen started
talking about the tiger blood and the
thing Charlie Sheen got on Twitter one
tweet Charlie Sheen sold out an entire
theater tour like big ass theater tour a
whole tour sold out on one tweet because
everybody was just so down and ready to
go buy a ticket to go watch Charlie
Sheen meltdown on stage and and like
three years I'm sober at that point for
three years and I could not help but
think man
Charlie Sheen's kind of killing it right
now he's the most famous guy in the
whole world if I Got Loaded
yeah I was like I actually had to fight
off temptation to get loaded because
Charlie Sheen was getting so much
attention right no yeah and that like me
and my girl even like once we started
going so viral for the the scene with
the other guy or whatever
we started to realize like oh anything
we say or do regarding our relationship
right now in particular will be so viral
and I was and she even suggested like I
mean we should fight like maybe we
should have like a fake fight thing and
I was like I thought about it for a
little bit I'm like nah we can't do it
because it's like as soon as we start
like that's really playing with fire
right there's like when you start
creating fake narratives to get
attention I'm like that's what I'm not
willing to do like we can joke around
and troll a little bit but I definitely
I'm not trying to like get to the point
where me and you are like creating fake
[__] in our life
you can't deceive your audience but
anything unstable really like harnesses
energy like fousey has had 50 000 live
viewers on Kik streaming like for you
know a couple weeks now which is like I
think honestly like a couple months ago
he might have had like a thousand people
watching him and now he's like 50 000
just because everybody likes watching a
NASCAR race where they think that they
might see a car accident you know right
yeah I mean like everybody that has like
a manic episode seems to go I mean Aaron
Carter every time Britney Spears
speaks a word she's on TMZ like I wonder
where the free Brittany people are at
now like are the free Brittany people
like yeah okay
that makes me wish that I had gone with
my gut a little bit more because when
they were going hard trying to free
Britney I remember just thinking like
nah bro like they need to keep her ass
locked up she is not good like she needs
this support system around her but I
didn't want to say it on Twitter because
I didn't want to get attacked and now
I'm seeing it play out and I'm like [__]
I should have like really staked that
claim because I know that I know her
like a husband or like soon to be
ex-husband because I used to work out
the same gym as him and I would just be
working out next to this guy all the
time we always talk about random [__]
talk about working out whatever but I
never had the balls to just be like
so what the [__] you doing with the
psychopath right you know I always
wanted to ask him like what do you do
because he's like bro
no homo but like beautiful man like
extremely good looking he's like on the
cover of like you know exercise
magazines and [__] like that and now and
I was just always wondering like bro
you're like dating this crazy person
does he get paid out when he divorces
her they were only together for a year
so no well yeah plus like that would be
the gnarliest prenup of all time I feel
like his name is Sam it's the top right
guy right there actually if you want to
yeah but I feel like there's when Bill
Murray got divorced I remember they were
talking about it on a show like he was
married for 13 years he had a prenup and
she's still got a [__] load of money and
they're like yeah well and prenups
really really don't do anything because
she still got paid out so I wonder yeah
when I did my prenup I realized that
there's you know they're not gonna let
you do a prenup that just like
completely [__] your partner like you
have to like like the the thing that
they did with ours is basically like if
we split up after a year I don't really
have to do anything thing if we split it
after five years then the person who
makes more money kind of has to like you
know compensate the other person more if
it's 10 years then it reaches like a
certain level which I do think is fair
because it's like yeah you know if if my
wife gives me you know 10 years of her
prime reproductive years and she's kind
of like primarily you know she's taking
the care of the kid more than I am and
you know that's like I try to do as much
as I can but ultimately
that's like unpaid labor and the you
know whatever kind of settlement you do
when you get divorced or whatever that's
basically like compensating for how much
time the wife probably spent taking time
away from her career to help with the
kids which I do think is fair even
though a lot of times you hear about
people having to pay you know it's 80
grand a month and [__] you're like oh
that doesn't sound fair at all yeah yeah
Kevin Costner is paying like 130 000 a
month oh that's on TMZ
Kevin Costner's uh
a stranger ex-wife
000 a month won't cut it yeah yeah
remember Dr Dre's wife got uh the money
it was like ninety thousand dollars a
month laundry bill or something like I
mean it was an insane amount of payout
but I I didn't know Kevin Costner was
worth 400 million dollars yeah no that's
it's for sure all like a percentage of
how much you're bringing in because yeah
I mean like I haven't seen people saying
that about Britney Spears as uh they got
Sam that she's divorcing right now where
it's like his apartment I guess is 10
grand a month and I've seen a lot of
people on Twitter like these [__]
rich people like my apartment is three
thousand dollars a month why does this
guy need a ten thousand dollar a month
spot and I'm like I don't think Britney
Spears is pulling up to hang out with a
guy at a three thousand dollar a month
spot in L.A like you got to realize
there's levels to this [__] like I'm I'm
pretty sure because like wherever he
lives is probably like a like at Beverly
Hills or some [__] probably like in
Summerlin next to Oprah yeah like his
ten thousand dollar a month spot is
probably not some crazy baller spot it's
probably just in a really nice area
where you need to spend ten thousand
dollars to get anything right yeah he
and and I heard that like he he's made a
couple investments in like tech
companies that like blew up really and
that's how he was able to when when that
did blow up he was able to fund the
Hatfield in McCoys like he funded the
whole production but like
I mean he is one of the best actors of
all time but 400 million dollars is is
quite a lot no that's for real that's
got to be I mean isn't Samuel L Jackson
the highest grossing actor of all time
but I mean does he have more than Kevin
Costner
um
I mean you can never account you can
never trust the celebrity net worth
Samuel Jackson five billion oh five
bills I mean he's yeah
he's been in the most movies of any
actor he must just have crazy
Investments and [__] you know because
it's like it's all about what you're
gonna do with it like if you could make
400 million and just put it in the bank
that's one thing if you make make a
couple million and you invest it
intelligently and all of a sudden it's
worth so much money you're not going to
become a billionaire by just being an
actor you know right I don't think yeah
I mean I've been waiting to hear the
rock joined the billion dollar club like
he's close or is he in it I mean I would
think like I would think too like nobody
hustles harder or pushes more stuff than
the rock it's crazy that hip-hop lost a
billionaire everybody had Kanye and then
he just made some bad decisions and he's
lost his billionaire status
overnight they dropped them from like
over over a billion to like 400 million
at a certain point yeah oh wow 1.5 to 4
because that's when uh Adidas let him go
right you never know how accurate this
is going to be but this is this has been
why I mean anything he does Forbes start
saying it like when florib says oh now
they're Amelia they just became a
billion then I believe let me do Taylor
Swift
I mean Jesus Christ I'm pretty sure she
made a billion dollars like on this tour
yeah yeah they had they had a picture of
her and um who is Justin Bieber's ex
Ariana Grande yeah and it was like
Justin Bieber's ex's Ariana Grande I
don't think so yeah yeah a long time
Selena Gomez we had a picture of Taylor
Swift and you're right that would be way
too epic
yeah I'm sorry I'm not really up to date
these people are all the same to me like
I can't really tell the difference yeah
I mean look at it 2.2 billion
and that's just ticket sales so think
about merch yeah I mean Jesus my girl
went she spent like a couple Grand on a
ticket and she went dude Isaac's girl
wins and she said she there was people
waiting the night before to get merch
she couldn't even buy merch because the
line was so long they rented out a
separate Stadium for the merch oh that's
insane that's what that's what she told
me man bless bless her heart man I'm not
mad at that well damn
I think we're in good shape brother yeah
man it's nice to make a return to this
van yeah that was a pleasure talking to
you yeah man I I like I enjoyed time and
your girlfriend's very hot too we didn't
really get to follow up on that but they
had her pulled out for like 10 minutes
I'm kind of like I don't want to be just
staring at this
my life just look at that I'm talking
about micro penises yeah I just kept
looking over at Adam he's just staring
yeah the reason why I was asking those
questions about like having your wife
slept with another man she did a scene
with browsers before we met Okay so
and it hasn't come out yet so I'm just
like oh I know the time is Gonna Come
where it's going to come out and I'm
gonna see it right I'm gonna try not to
see it but I don't know if like you know
what I mean I mean I don't know if my
advice is really like valuable to a
person who like I feel like porn is all
about like
steadily gradually make like making
yourself numb to more and more extreme
[__] because for me at this point like
it didn't really feel like the biggest
thing in the world for my girl to do
that scene but it still felt like a
thing you know it's still like
definitely a thing and for you as
somebody who's like clearly going
through this for the first time I would
just say you gotta take it upon yourself
as a as a personal challenge to be able
to like weather that storm and I think
it gets easier over time because I mean
and especially like you know she did it
before you so it's kind of like yeah
yeah you can't really be that bent out
of shape I just I I just know like so
many people are gonna see it probably a
bunch of my friends and all that stuff
so did you watch the porn yes are you
gonna watch the porn I keep saying no
but I probably am
yeah because if you don't watch it then
they can kind of use it against you like
your friends and stuff can be like well
when she did this and then your brain's
gonna go crazy like [__] she did that
like but if you see it then you'll kind
of know what to be expecting yeah yeah
all right cool man damn thank you
brother Stevo yeah man appreciate you
guys for real thank you much love to see
you so okay how many times you jerked
off in the past year uh I went 144 days
and then and then after I started dating
somebody then it was all off the table
oh okay yeah yeah but yeah
respectable I thought you're going to
come out with that first no I forgot
stop recording
I have a big I have a date at 6 30.
all right cut
there you have it ladies and gentlemen
adam22 is my boy and check out the
podcast I recorded with him too like uh
the story about how and why we had to
reschedule is pretty interesting I went
ahead and admitted that it was my fault
okay
um and uh what can I say man I love
adam22 I love you for sticking around to
the very end of the Wild Ride podcast
and as I told you in the very beginning
I am on the road I am on tour it is the
last times I will ever be performing The
Bucket List show and if you get a chance
to be there then jump on it I'll see you
guys on the road and I love you tons
yeah dude
yes